getting faster and faster. That's magic. I've
become able to move quickly in the wall style. It
was difficult to run immediately after signing the contract, but Tono and Mi-dono
have trained me, so I learned how to run on water the other day.  Those
two
do it well. The wall of doves is great. Thank you for your compliments. That's a
lie. Sensei was able to read the movements perfectly.
Is this really a battle between spellcasters? If this is the case, then how about
another counter spell? As
expected.
Well, after the earth, there is no water at the same time, and
this is all thanks to the staff. Elders and
dwarves do a really good job. It
can't be helped to make them pull back. Let's end it with the
next day.  If the two
of us on the hunt can't talk about being teachers even if it's our first time,
then Kodai was the prize and if it was that powerful, the magic that was damaged is
gone
[Music] There might
not even be a single one left.